Speaker 1: OK, let's follow up on a couple
of different stories that we've been covering
for some time, you might remember that sort
of in the in the middle of the 2020 era of
the pandemic, there was this plot to kidnap
the Democratic Michigan governor, Gretchen
Whitmer, and a number of people were arrested
for that.
We have now learned what the consequences
will be for one of the coconspirators, I guess
we would call them there.
A Michigan man who admitted to taking part
in an extremist groups plot to kidnap Gretchen
Whitmer in retaliation for covid restrictions
was sentenced yesterday to over six years
in prison.
The man is 25 year old Tai Garbin is the only
person to have pleaded guilty out of the more
than a dozen men facing state and federal
charges stemming from the plot.
So understand that this guy got more than
six years.
He pleaded guilty and cooperated.
The others are presumably going to trial and
this guy still got six years.
So just think about what might be coming for
some of the other individuals here.
Five of those charged in federal court pleaded
not guilty and face trial in October.
U.S. District Judge Robert Jonker sentenced
Garbin to 75 months in prison, three years
of probation and a 2500 dollar fine.
During the sentencing hearing, Garbin apologized
to Wittmer, who was not present.
This guy essentially threw himself at the
mercy of the court, pleaded guilty, cooperated
and apologized and still got more than six
years, at least in theory.
Of course, it'll depend on exactly what charges
others are convicted of, if at all.
You could be looking at way longer prison
sentences for the others.
The individual, Ty Garbin said, quote, First,
I would like to take this opportunity to apologize
to Governor Gretchen Gretchen Whitmer and
her family.
I've had a lot of time to reflect on my actions
and I never realized what my actions would
have caused to her, but also her family.
I can't even imagine the amount of stress
and fear her family members felt because of
my actions.
And for that I am truly sorry.
Garbin also apologized to his friends and
family.
I never took into consideration the emotional
effect that my actions would take on them.
And for that I was truly selfish to not take
into consideration my family members that
have meant so much to me.
He expressed the desire to continue to de
radicalize himself and help prevent others
from becoming radicalized and going down the
same path.
So that's great.
If that stuff is true, it very well might
be completely disingenuous.
And what his lawyer said, say this in order
to get the lightest possible sentence, it
doesn't really matter.
He was willing to do it.
And what I am so so two thoughts here, basically.
First of all, they have to throw the book
at these guys.
It has to be made very clear that it is not
it is not a serious modern society.
If you can plot to kidnap one of the the top
state official, the governor, and get away
with a slap on the wrist, it can't happen.
And so this is a guy who expressed remorse,
genuine or disingenuous, I don't know.
But he expressed remorse.
He cooperated.
He is getting all the right buzzwords.
I want to Redrado de radicalize myself and
I apologize to everybody and pleaded guilty.
And more than six years in prison, he will
now have to do the other eleven individuals.
And again, only some of those we know sort
of the path to trial that is taking place.
But the other up to eleven individuals, could
they end up with more than a decade in prison?
We don't know.
We'll have to wait.
But this is exactly the way that this needs
to be handled, because this is extraordinarily
serious.
And unfortunately, you know, there's this
very similar dynamic with the January six
Trump rioters.
And we've started to see some of those sentences
come in.
We covered one on the bonus show, two, three,
maybe it was more like four weeks ago.
And we can kind of argue over, OK, eight years,
twelve, six, fifteen.
And then if for good behavior in prison overcrowding,
they'll probably serve half whatever ultimately
is the number of days and weeks and months
that these individuals serve, it has to be
made very clear that this is what they did
on January 6th was worse than just showing
up and trespassing at a business.
Right.
Like on paper, the literal charges that might
be there, isolated from the political reality
and the movement and the mob mentality that
that was part of what was going on might not
be as bad as ten, twelve years in prison,
but that the overall event that they participated
in and its relationship to having a functioning
democracy, et cetera, makes it worse.
There's sort of an enhancement component there
that has to be taken into consideration.
And I hope that we see the book.
Ron at the Trump writers from January 6th,
as much as hopefully the book will continue
to be thrown at the accused here, if they
are found guilty, of course, or if they strike
plea deals when it comes to the plot to kidnap
Governor Gretchen Whitmer.
And it's actually crazy that because of all
the different things that were going on at
this time and because of the complete daily
scandal of the Trump administration at the
time that this was going on, this all this
feels like it was a relatively minor story
and a long time ago.
But this is this is crazy.
This is crazy.
A concerted effort to kidnap a governor and
so far, one down and many more to go to Tigard
and will have to spend more than six years
in prison, maybe only three for good behavior.
Right.
We'll have to see about that.
But we'll continue to follow other sentences
that come forward.